so the way this happened mark was the
following and we got we got to make a
plan okay okay I'm yelling at Fred cuz
fred is a good song right yeah and I
said Fred write me a [ __ ] hit song
yeah so he went home and took me
seriously wrote the song sent it to me I
said this sounds reasonable to be a song
and I thought like maybe I could sing
like that guy Fred Schneider in the
b-52s cuz he's like yeah rock man baby
yeah yeah I could yell out some [ __ ] I
have a hit song I don't want to do much
we'll get a bunch of girls who can
really sing yeah I said to Baba Booey I
said you gotta get me one of these young
hot producers yeah he's got some
gravitas in the business who's known
what the kids like yeah so Gary I called
you immediately I guess he had met you
somewhere yeah and you said yes you
weren't supposed to say I'm sorry yeah
you [ __ ] me up yeah I'm all nervous I
mean I'm sure everyone comes and says
this but like I grew up New York k-rock
listening every day on school I'm a
massive fan of the show so when I got
this text from my friend Ross who works
at Syria saying can I give Gary
Dell'Abate your number I was like this
is the coolest random text I've ever
seen yes yeah so we talk he starts
telling me about the song he sends me
the Fred demo and it's it's cool he
wrote you a hit song yes of course and I
think that like I think that we can
really make something pretty great I
know what you mean about the the Fred
Schneider I love Love Shack I love the
b-52s I think let's make a deal yeah I'm
gonna get in there today I'll try I was
practicing less okay I don't know what
I'm doing practice I was I was I was the
paint God Beth was at home she was out
can I can I tell you something in my
experience as a producer what I do and
it doesn't matter whether the artist is
like Bruno Mars or Ghostface Killah or
Gaga Bradley whoever I'm working with
everybody has a superpower special
talent you have a voice that is the
golden voice that millions of people
love I'm sorry you know I mean I do you
just do just when you talk so like all I
have to do I don't want to make you do
anything that you don't usually do
whatever like now take that voice that
platinum thing anyway and just make that
the star of the show and like that's why
we're gonna record it with your vocals
like at this desk so you sound exactly
like you do to the millions of people
every day cuz like that's what we want
to hear I like what you're saying in
other words be my saying yourself don't
get inhibited don't get uptight give the
people what they want give the people
say you can make up what you
I mean you've poins plenty of nonsense
amazing words and phrases all we have to
do is put those in and then you know you
said you wanted some girl parts so I
went you know the girls in the band hi
more big fans of the show I can't
believe you got them to do the back I'll
listen it's I mentioned I'm do the cover
let them do the heavy lifting but I'm
saying yeah I called them up I was like
what are you guys doing tomorrow they're
like I don't know we have this we got
press I'm like I'm working on this
number how is certain they're like we'll
be there at 8:30 well hi I'm said that
yes so so like we made this song in a
way that like does sing the bits you
could say anything you could say that
stuff that Fred wrote forever oh you hit
something we can take a lot of those
there I might live a little be prepared
I want that I'm getting a little pumped
up I could see why you're valuable is a
producer you're running inspire me well
it's just true like you have something
you have a gift all I have to do is like
put that gift in a shiny bow and like
put it on a nice B and don't you have a
hit and don't be uptight about directing
me it's okay ego is out the window I am
a Robin tell em I'm a professional
you know what to do I have no ego okay
my parents took care of that